[Musique]
lorsque maria et gabriel ont déménagé
ils sont allés sur le site du service
québécois de changement d'adressé qui
permet de faire d'un seul coup un
changement auprès de plusieurs
organismes dont la saaq maria coche tout
vite fait bien fait mais ça ne remarque
pas cette note
il faut communiquer avec la saaq si on
possède un véhicule en copropriété ce
qui est justement le cas de maria et
gabriel pourquoi cette note
parce que ce vieux système informatique
est incapable de traiter une demande
concernant plus d'un propriétaire
le certificat d'immatriculation de
l'auto de maria et gabriel l'est donc
enregistré à leur ancienne adresse sans
qu'il le sache
c'est donc à l'ancienne adresse qui est
envoyé la vie de renouvellement et un
jour ce qui devait arriver arrive une
policière leur demande leur certificat
d'immatriculation qui est expiré ce qui
leur vaut une contravention 482 $
le fin mot de l'histoire si vous êtes un
propriétaire moderne avec la saaq vous
devez procéder à l'ancienne